c'est officiel jean philippe lucet
devenu maire de bois d'arcy ce samedi 7
novembre
il succède à philippe benassaya
démissionnaire après avoir été élu
député pour respecter la loi du non
cumul des mandats
le nouveau maire n'est pas inconnu dans
la commune il y a toujours vécu et
occupe depuis quelques années des
fonctions politiques
j'ai l'occasion au cours de ces derniers
mandats afin tout cas depuis 2014 à être
sur quatre délégations des différentes
dont les finances qui me permets moi
d'avoir une vision globale mais assez
globale de la situation et la proximité
que j'ai avec avec notre ancien maire et
député aujourd'hui fait que j'ai une
bonne connaissance aussi des sujets
importants pour la commune un nouveau
maire qui entend poursuivre les projets
engagés par son prédécesseur
aujourd'hui c'est une belle journée
parce que c'est une journée qui consacre
aussi la continuité des projets la
continuité de l'équipe ce que j'ai mis
en marche ce que j'ai mis en projet je
suis à la fois heureux pour
jean-philippe heureux pour l'équipe est
rassuré parce que tours a continué comme
avant et je serai bien sûr là pour
continuer à veiller à la bonne
application du programme
l'opposition de son côté estime qu'il ya
eu un manque de concertation
nous trouvons que c'est bien dommage de
ne pas avoir laissé le choix que
monsieur lui s'était imposée dès les
premières minutes du départ de monsieur
benassaya et que dans les guides du
maire comme chacun le sait il est bien
noté que ce n'est pas au maire sortant
de donner le nom de son
successeur trois grands projets à venir
pour jean-philippe plus la
reconstruction du centre de loisirs de
la colombe la crèche ambroise paré et le
marché couvert